the liberal Global Elite have descended
from their private jets into a luxurious
little town high up in the Swiss Alps
for the annual meeting of the world
economic Forum where they hope to plan
how all the rest of us will live but if
you say that you will be called a crazy
right-wing conspiracy theorist unless
you're John Kerry when you stop and
think about it it's pretty extraordinary
that we select group of human beings
because of whatever touched us at some
point in our lives are able to sit in a
room and come together
and actually talk about saving the
planet I mean it's so almost
extraterrestrial to think about quote
saving the planet if you said that to
most people most people they think
you're just a crazy tree-hugging Lefty
liberal you know do-good or whatever and
and there's no relationship but really
that's where we are
for the record John I do not think that
you people are do-gooders I think you
are do batters okay I am half convinced
that you are all extraterrestrials but I
am I am not convinced about the
do-gooder thing what I'm most convinced
about that John Kerry said is that these
people are Elite they are a select group
of people where the select past the
caviar and they want to become the
masters of our Collective future but if
you say that you will be called a crazy
right-wing conspiracy theorist
unless you're the founder of the world
economic Forum Klaus Schwab what does it
need to master the future
I think
to have a platform
we're all stakeholders of global Society
are engaged
governments business civil societies
Young Generation that I could go on
I think is the first step
to
meet all the challenges
this is how we will Masters the future
so what we know here from their own
words is they're Elites they meet up in
a wealthy inaccessible ski resort Town
surrounded by the Swiss military and the
private police force and they intend to
reorder the entire world if you
acknowledge all those things to
celebrate them
that's perfectly fine then you are an
insightful participant in the
Progressive Society of the future but if
you point out those facts to criticize
them you are a conspiracist kook and a
danger to mankind I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
show my favorite comment yesterday is
from Johnny s who says make our eggs on
gas stoves in the morning damn Michael
we're not all millionaires like you you
make a really great point because when I
would go shopping for eggs back when I
was a bachelor I'd go and eggs would
cost a dollar or maybe two dollars and
then just the other day sweet little
Elisa brought this up to me she said Mac
I was complaining about how the prices
of something had gone up she says Mac do
you know what we pay for eggs
so do I want to know she goes you don't
want to know Meg
and even you know she likes the fancy
eggs the eggs with the college education
and so I I'm I I will go bankrupt on the
eggs you're right it won't matter if
they take my gas stove away from me
because I will have nothing to cook on
the gas stove at least though that might
rejuvenate me a little bit you know I
won't become quite so bloated I won't be
overweight I'll look a little younger
and fresher when you want to look a
little younger and fresher you've got to
check out genucel right now go to
genucel.com
Knowles our friends over at genu cell
skin care have exciting news to
celebrate in 2023 they are introducing
their new microbiome moisturizer which
uses the power of probiotics to Target
skin redness pesky wrinkles Fine Lines
patchy blotches and other signs of
premature aging these are the same
probiotics that are in your yogurt as it
turns out these super ingredients can
have the same nourishing benefits on
your skin as they do for your stomach
probiotic extracts Target bad bacteria
and restore balance to your Skin's
protective barrier now every gen you
sell most popular package includes their
new probiotic moisturizer free with your
order I absolutely love these guys I am
always skeptical of the stay younger
look fresher kinds of products so I
insisted I said I gotta I gotta get some
of this product to try it if I'm going
to endorse it and I really really rely
on these guys I really really like them
you can get geniusella's most popular
package for seventy seven zero percent
off go to genucel.com Knowles get your
probiotic moisturizer today code Knolls
at checkout get an extra 10 off your
whole purchase genucel.com slash Knowles
a lot of kooky stuff being talked about
at the world economic forum
this is my favorite though
you know they talk about how we're going
to eat the bugs it's not a conspiracy
theory that's from the world economic
Forum website you know they talk about
how we're not going to get to drive our
cars that's not a conspiracy theory
that's from the world economic Forum
website
you know they talk about how we're not
going to own anything we're going to
have no property and we're going to be
really really happy about that not a
conspiracy theory from the world
economic Forum website but but the
agenda item that always seems to pop up
not just among the Davos crowds
specifically at the world economic Forum
but it always pops up among the liberal
Elite
overpopulation
an overpopulation the idea
that there are too many people in the
world we got to stop having any more
babies we gotta Maybe
hurry along the people who are already
in the world to their final destination
here
that remains a top agenda item even as
it has been disproven time and time
again for 50 years now disproven
the world economic Forum admits this
that overpopulation has been kind of
disproven and then doubles down on it
anyway they say even as birth rates
decline
overpopulation remains a global
Challenge and they they have this graph
here it says Malthus didn't see this one
coming referring to the malthusian idea
that there are too many people in the
world and we need to reduce the
population they say the vision of a
post-apocalyptic overpopulated world has
been a favorite nightmare scenario
science fiction writers and filmmakers
for decades but data from a variety of
sources including the UN and the World
Bank indicate that the total number of
live births is falling around the world
including in developing nations and
developed Nations some commentators have
suggested the decrease in fertility
rates is good news for our descendants
in previous generations national birth
rates were high however factors such as
new medicine and improved access to
education for women have dropped
fertility rates despite this though some
regions are still experiencing
significant population growth they're
talking about Africa they're talking
about parts of Asia and so this is a
really big problem and we've got to take
care of that
no one who complains about
overpopulation has ever been the good
guy
ever in history if you are complaining
about overpopulation you are on the bad
team okay
none of the people who complain about
overpopulation are ever volunteering
themselves to to take a ticket off the
ship
right it's always that someone else
shouldn't have life it's always that
someone else should hurry along and die
it's never that they themselves want to
do they want to go to parties and Davos
and they want to have nice drinks and
they want to have a bunch of hookers
apparently according to the reports
coming out of Davos there is just an
army of prostitutes descending on the
town because it's a big party and
there's more money than since going
around definitely more money than virtue
and so while they have their fun and
they eat their fancy foods and they
drink their fancy drinks and they
do various activities with their fancy
ladies of the night they talk about how
you should not even have the right to
live
forget about the right to a gas stove
forget about the right to eat beef
instead of crickets forget about the
right to drive your truck instead of
some stupid electric car even the right
to live they are going after
and it's all The Usual Suspects and
what's amazing is is
not just the the craziest things that
they say but that they try to ground
their agenda in in
political commentary that seems to have
a kernel of Truth a great example of
this saint Al Saint Al Gore took to
Davos to explain why we've got to cut
back on the oil subsidies
enough already enough
and I don't want to get sidetracked onto
what needs to happen but we need to
scale up climate Finance but we need
desperately to scale down anti-climate
Finance
and we are still subsidizing the burning
of fossil fuels globally at a rate 42
times larger than the subsidies for the
shift toward Renewables and EVS
Etc we need new leadership at the World
Bank we need them to scale up the
leverage and vastly increase the amounts
that are are committed and we need to
rein in the anti-climate activities of
the fossil industry
so a lot of Bluster a lot of we should
do this we should do that we're due to
run
my very unpopular agenda
sure that's typical politics but he made
a positive claim here the claim was that
we subsidize oil
and if you just heard that fact
you'd say well that seems kind of
strange oil is a very profitable
industry why is it that governments
around the world to the tune of what
half a trillion dollars a year are
subsidizing oil that seems corrupt we
should probably stop that until you you
ask the basic question okay
sure we subsidize oil why why do we
subsidize oil
and the reason we subsidize oil is so
that poor people don't freeze to death
in the winter
that's why we subsidize oil we don't
subsidize oil just because we like the
cut of the jib of the CEO of Exxon Mobil
the the people clamoring for the oil
subsidies are are people who are poor or
advocating on behalf of the poor because
people can't afford to heat their homes
people can't afford to fill their gas
tanks
why are we subsidizing oil we have a
national strategic petroleum Reserve is
that is that a subsidy of oil well it is
the state purchasing a lot of oil but
it's for National Defense which of those
things do you want to get rid of you
want the poor people to freeze to death
maybe they do I mean if you're worried
about overpopulation then maybe you do
you say well you know these people they
just need to go away I think of Yuval
Harare he's one of the contributors to
the world economic Forum some people
have called him a kind of philosopher of
the world economic Forum Yuval Harare
has said that in the future there's just
going to be all these useless people
all these useless people out there
who are just sucking up energy and he
was asked how are we going to deal with
these useless people and his answer was
drugs and video games play them full of
drugs keep them kind of busy keep them
kind of happy get them out of the way
that is the view of humanity from the
so-called do-gooders as John Kerry calls
them at the world economic forum and why
do they view Humanity this way because
they're standing way high up in the in
the Alps that's why it goes back to that
old wisdom from G.K Chesterton the old
father Brown stories say don't pray from
the tops of buildings don't pray from
Heights because from Heights people look
very very small people look like bugs
and then you end up wanting to feed them
bugs and wanting them to go away and and
viewing them as a kind of pest that
needs to be exterminated because of the
the Peril of overpopulation when you're
down on the ground when you are a
grounded person when you're when you're
looking up then you can see the heavens
and you can see that people are really
people and they're full-sized and they
look a lot like you they don't look a
lot like the people who go to Davos at
least not to the people who go to Davos
those people are extraterrestrial as far
as Carrie and the rest of those people
are concerned speaking of fossil fuels I
got to a story a little bit yesterday
and mentioned it
I want to drive it home which is these
gas stoves you know the libs threatened
to take away our gas stoves in the name
of climate change or Energy Efficiency
or whatever they tool around in their
private jets they fly all the way to
Davos but they're really worried about
you frying your eggs in the morning if
you can afford the price of eggs these
days
then they backed off it
there was a public outcry even a
Democrat Senator Joe manchin came out
and said you're not taking away my gas
stove this is a stupid idea they said no
we never wanted to take away your gas
stoves but we got them on tape the thing
is the internet is forever
and so we've got the head of the
consumer product safety commission just
last month coming out and saying yeah we
very possibly are going to take away
your gas stoves
what this whole story is about is not
gas not cooking not what they're going
to make us eat none of those things
specifically it's about the Liberals
taking our temperature
it in this way it relates to gas stoves
it's about figuring out what the
temperature is the libs do this all the
time they float some crazy idea and they
say it very confidently and then they
wait to see if we'll go along with it
this was the story of covid the story of
kovid was okay there's a virus that came
out of China that
almost certainly was engineered in a
laboratory and very likely was
engineered with our money through
through the very kind of research that
we were funding in the Wuhan Institute
of virology they lied to us about that
but put a pause there anyway a virus
comes out of China and the virus results
in for most people a mild cough and
sometimes you lose your sense of smell
or taste but for some people it can be
really bad but for the vast majority of
people it's it's not that big a deal and
what the libs did was they said and this
came straight out of the world economic
Forum these are the words of Klaus
Schwab he said zakovid 19 lockdown
presents opportunity to reset our world
and then you had all of these uh rulers
you had King Charles III at the time the
Prince of Wales using these exact
phrases you had Joe Biden repeating this
kind of phrase Justin Trudeau in Canada
reciting this kind of phrase the prime
minister of New Zealand and many other
world leaders all saying okay we're
going to use kovid as an excuse to push
through a bunch of policy that we all
want to do so what do they do the libs
come out and they say okay okay because
there's this kind of a coronavirus
flu-like kind of virus coming out of out
of China we're going to completely shut
down all your churches
okay yeah you're good and then what did
we say most people said nothing I said
okay well you have to shut down my
churches I might get a mild cough so of
course you have to take away my right to
practice My Religion yeah okay and good
okay they're gonna go with us all right
and okay and we're gonna shut down all
your jobs and take away your small
businesses and gonna we're gonna force
you to just buy products from really big
businesses and it's going to represent
the largest transfer of wealth in
recorded history
and what happened some small business
owners fought back
daily wire fought back as best we could
we actually won a case in the Supreme
Court in the vaccine mandate
but overall what happened people they
just okay they said all right we won't
go to work
okay
15 days to slow the Sprint 15 years to
slow the spread okay and then what did
the lips do they said okay and yeah and
you can't see your relatives either Yeah
Christmas is canceled you can't go to
Christmas and you can't hug anybody and
you can't you have to stand six feet
away from people why I don't know and
you have to wear a hanky on your face if
you don't wear a hanky on your face the
whole world there everyone's gonna die
yeah yeah you go okay all right and then
this this vaccine that this this uh
extremely risky gene therapy that we've
been developing for like five minutes
now uh you all have to take it even if
your risk from covid is statistically
nothing you
okay and you got to take a second one
hey Bill they're doing it can you
believe that Klaus can you believe these
Lemmings are doing it that that's what
they're doing and so when they floated
the gas stove and obviously it got so
much worse with covet but when they
float the gas stove thing that's exactly
what they're doing they're saying man
what's the what's the craziest thing we
can say right now
that will show our dominance over people
and will give us in principle even more
power over their lives we're going to
take away their stoves yeah we're gonna
get we're gonna go into their kitchens
and take away their stove so they
are these dummies going to go along with
that and fortunately people said no that
was the line
stabbed me in the arm with an
experimental drug that was unfortunately
not the line make me put a hanky on my
face for three years unfortunately that
was not the line but at least the stove
was the line and so they back off a
little bit but they're going to come
back at it they're just constantly
recalibrating where your tolerance lies
and then they're going to Peg their
predations exactly to where that point
is
speaking of taking the temperature
the 2024 presidential race is still
going on a lot of us have forgotten
about that
hasn't really been in the news lately
but
it is very much in the news again
because one of President Trump's top
advisors
who now happens to be the governor of
Arkansas that would be Sarah Sanders was
just brought on a news show
she was asked a simple question
your old boss
for whom you were one of his closest
most trusted advisors he's running for
president again
do you endorse him
here is Governor Sanders's answer
2024 your bio on your official page as
Governor describes you as a quote
trusted confidante of President Trump
have you talked to him about his 24 run
will you endorse him in that
my focus right now has been on 2022
winning the election in November
preparing through transition and getting
ready to take offices I did this past
week I love the president have a great
relationship with him I know her country
would be infinitely better off if he was
in office right now instead of Joe Biden
but right now my focus isn't 2024 it's
focusing here in Arkansas and doing what
we can to empower the people of this
state and make sure that I'm delivering
on the promises that I laid out over the
course of the last two years what kind
of timeline would you have for making a
decision do you want to see who else
gets into the primary will you wait for
the nominee
my again my focus isn't on 2024 it's on
what we can deliver in this legislative
session
in other words I'm not answering your
question Shannon and I think it's fair
enough I love Sarah Sanders I thought
she was a phenomenal press secretary she
gets it politically she's tough she's
smart I think she's going to make an
excellent governor of Arkansas
and what she's doing here is politically
I think very wise
she has taken the temperature and she
sees that it is not in her political
interest to come out for Trump or maybe
for any presidential candidate this
early her constituents don't want to see
it at least I think in her view
Republicans I'm not sure want to see it
and Trump
love him as I do he's not nearly as
strong politically as he was two years
ago and so she's just taking that
temperature and this is why I happen to
love Sarah Sanders I think she's a great
force for good in American politics but
even for for politicians that I don't
think are a Force for good I still pay
attention to what they say especially on
questions like this that involve making
political predictions trying to get on
the good side of the winner not getting
on the bad side of somebody who might
win in in another possible world I I pay
attention to what they say because if
you know a politician's name 99 times
out of 100 that means that politician is
a VIP MVP
a-lister Varsity politician they are
very very good at being politicians and
taking the temperature and knowing where
people stand and so right now Sarah
Sanders is hedging her bets a little bit
and I think that's fair enough it's
totally her right to do that I don't see
any reason to endorse any presidential
candidate this early but I will tell you
if Trump were the dominant force in the
Republican party that he was a couple of
years ago and that many people thought
he would be in the 2024 race a lot of
people predicted including potential
candidates predicted that if Trump got
in he would clear the field that has not
happened and that is that is being
reflected when even some of his closest
advisors and supporters are saying well
I'm gonna see how this thing plays out
speaking of presidents
Joe Biden showed off another one of his
talents the other day Joe Biden is a
talent not only for getting himself
elected but Joe Biden we know has a
talent for storytelling we know Joe
Biden was a genius in school he
graduated with what did he say three
undergraduate degrees three did he say
he got a full academic scholarship and
graduated top of his class and I don't
think maybe that stuff didn't turn out
to be true he's a great swimmer you know
he used to go swimming with Corn Pop he
had very hairy legs and Well on to all
of these talents Joe Biden apparently is
a singer
and for Martin Luther King Day Joe Biden
decided to sing
happy birthday to Martin Luther King's
daughter-in-law
well look my wife has a role in her
family when somebody's birthday sing
happy birthday you ready happy birthday
to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear Valley
happy birthday to you
not exactly Marilyn Monroe to Jack
Kennedy and then what I what I love
about Biden's rendition is how human it
was because we've all done that if we're
at a birthday party or you know we're in
a restaurant let's say someone goes over
and sings Happy Birthday and you maybe
you join in but you don't know the
person's name so you say happy birthday
dearest
except Biden did that singing alone
[Music]
when you when you sing that in a group
the idea is that the people who do know
the person's name will drown it out but
Joe Biden is singing this alone into a
microphone and he's the president of the
United States and he has no idea what
this woman's name is no one forced him
to sing this song this was his own idea
clearly losing his touch a little bit
shows you something else too though
you know I didn't really talk about
Martin Luther King day which is one of
the saint saintly feasts in the liberal
Liturgical Calendar it goes along with
uh women's History Month Black History
Month gay pride month gay pride actually
gets two months now they get June and
October all these different months and
and just as liturgical calendars have
holy months they also have holy days and
feasts and one of the prominent ones for
the Liberals is Saint Martin Luther King
Day
and one of the reasons I don't
acknowledge the day is that
nobody really cares about Martin Luther
King peop everybody pretends to care
about Martin Luther King but nobody
actually cares about Martin Luther King
and certainly not the people who most
exploit his name
like Joe Biden showing up at I believe
an event for the National Action Network
uh Al Sharpton's Shakedown organization
and he goes there and he pretends he
pretends that he fought with the Civil
Rights activists and he makes up all
these stories and he was out there
marching on Washington with corn pop or
whatever and he saw Martin Luther King
lean so much to me and his
daughter-in-law means so much to me
what's your name I don't know whatever
anyway
I love black people give me money
support me if you're not if you don't
vote for me you're not black
happy Martin Luther King day if you
don't vote for me I'm depriving you of
your racial identity it's just so
pathetic it's just pure pandering and I
have to tell you I I am delighted in on
those occasions when he's caught doing
it
happy birthday
jack happy birthday here Jack Corn Pop
come on man you know happy birthday
someone who better vote for me speaking
of racial politics
San Francisco has solved racism
it's over now
we can pack it up we don't need Martin
Luther King Day anymore we don't need
any statues of weird arms grabbing onto
various appendages or
fecal sorts of things or genital
sculptures we don't you know the one in
Boston we don't need that anymore
because San Francisco cured racism had
they cure it they're going to give black
people five million dollars
and then it's cured I hope I certainly
hope so San Francisco reparations
committee proposed a plan to City
officials
last month that would pay long-time
black residents of Northern California
Metropol of the northern California
Metropolitan city five million dollars
each
well granting total debt forgiveness for
decades of systematic repression
I have to remind you I don't know if
you're a history buff or not but when
you look at slavery and the history of
California one of the funny things is
California never had slavery
it's one of the most notable states in
the country that never had slavery
because in fact the slavery question
into California was one of the causes of
the Civil War which ended slavery
over 150 years ago I would remind you so
so people in California who were never
slaves
are gonna make five million dollars each
paid for by a state that never had
slavery
San Francisco
African-American reparations advisory
committee just submitted this report to
the Board of Supervisors
it's a quote centuries of harm and
destruction of black lives black bodies
and black communities should be met with
centuries of repair if you look at San
Francisco it's very much A Tale of Two
Cities that's it is San Francisco is A
Tale of Two Cities it's a tale of of the
tech oligarchs and heroin addicts
The Tale of Two Cities is not broken
down evenly on race
it's broken down on the zillionaire rich
kids who became Tech
oligarchs
and the people who are hooked on drugs
that those very same Tech oligarchs are
encouraging to do the drugs and handing
them all needles and letting them
languish in the streets and die of
exposure
that would be that would if you wanted
reparations or really if you just wanted
a kind of social welfare policy you'd
probably Target those people you
probably wouldn't pay five million
dollars to every single black person in
in a city that never had slavery now why
is it five million bucks
I know exactly why the committee
recommended five million dollars what
were they going to do
what were they going to do this issue is
so absurd
the the issue is so purely emotional and
so devoid of reason
for the reasons I've just mentioned and
others
that these people on the committee must
be terrified that if they offered a
number that was too low they'd be called
racists they'd be said to make light of
slavery
they came back and they said okay look
slavery we've done the calculation and
because
some people maybe uh a small number of
the people in the city the black people
maybe some of their ancestors
were slaves at some point like 150 years
ago or 200 years ago or 300 years ago
and so
by my calculation we're going to give
you ten thousand dollars oh that
wouldn't that wouldn't cut it
raises another question what about the
many black people who also descend from
slave owners
does it cancel out
if you just if a black person
descends from a slave owner
when I think of the first officially
declared slave for Life arbitrary
arbitrarily declared slave for life not
for punishment for a crime or something
like that the first arbitrary
arbitrarily declared slave for life in
America was a black guy
this was in Virginia and the first
arbitrarily declared slave owner
was also a black guy he was a black
angolan guy so if you're a black person
and you descend from that black guy who
was the first judicially announced slave
owner in America do you have to pay
reparations you surely shouldn't get
reparations what if you descend from
both of those guys does it cancel out
and it's even let's say it's five
million bucks okay that's it I I could
get behind that plan
I don't know how many black people in
San Fran qualify for this
I don't know let's say it's got it would
be like it could be a lot of people you
know 10 people that's 50 million bucks
I'm no I'm no mathematician 100 people
500 million bucks
thousand people five billion dollars
ten thousand people 50 billion I don't
care I don't care what the number is
let's say it's 50
billion dollars
chump change compared to what we send
over to Ukraine I'd be willing to spend
it if if I were convinced that 50
billion dollars could could solve
America's racial Obsession oh that would
be a great investment I'd be totally
fine with that I don't care that's fine
governments wastes money on all sorts of
nonsense 50 billion great
will that do it
will
will the five million dollar payments in
San Francisco
cause everyone to shut up about racism
from now on and I never want to hear it
again I don't want to hear one gripe I
don't want to hear one
passive aggressive comment about how
terrible America is not I think that
should be the plan this is the
requirement I endorse the San Francisco
reparations committee's plans I
encourage other other municipalities
around the country maybe even the
federal government to follow it
x amount of money anybody who can make a
plausible claim that they descended from
slavery and their ancestors were
oppressed or whatever they get a huge
amount of money
if they sign on the dotted line that
they will never ever again open their
yaps about the evils of systemic
oppression and how they could never make
anything of their lives because they're
great great great great great great
great great great great great great
grand uncle was a slave at some point in
the past fine by me that's great that's
that's my slavery reparations plan I'm
totally for it's just like how the
Knowles prenup plan I endorse prenups if
the prenup says that whichever party
ends the marriage forfeits all the
rights to the house and the money and
the kids if that's the prenup I totally
endorse prenups and if this is the
reparations plan when you sign on that
line and you take that money you got to
keep that trap shut about racism for the
rest of your life cool
frankly I think it's a good deal for the
public this January we are celebrating
the anniversary of one of the greatest
moments in Daily wire history after
months of us leading the legal battle
against the federal government and a
national do not comply campaign the
Supreme Court ruled in our favor and
blocked the Biden administration's
outrageous vaccine mandate this mandate
would have set a dangerous precedent
giving the unelected OSHA power over the
personal medical decisions of American
citizens the Supreme Court recognized
this gross power grab and made the right
decision we are so proud to have led the
charge in this fight but we could not
have done it without you
thousands of you join the daily wire and
over a million Americans signed our
petition against the mandates to
celebrate we are offering 40 4-0 off
annual memberships with the code do not
comply
if this mandate had gone into effect you
either would have lost your job or you
would have had to take the dangerous
fauci algae
we would have had to do it too I asked
Jeremy I said so what happens if we lose
this case he said oh we have to we have
to go along with the Mandate because one
will have made ourselves the biggest
target for the federal government so you
know they're going to come investigate
us and the moment they do investigate us
they're going to find out that we're not
mandating it and they're going to find
us hundreds of thousands of dollars a
day and whether we want to fight it or
not they will bankrupt the company
within two weeks it would have happened
and so standing up at the right time
with the right amount of Courage it
really really had a major impact to
celebrate one of the greatest moments in
Daily wire history get 40 off your
annual membership join now at
dailywire.com subscribe join the winning
team as we continue to crush the libs do
not comply that's the code for 40 off do
not comply
now on the topic of resentment
Angela Bassett
just won a best supporting actress at
the Golden Globes you didn't catch the
broadcast okay me neither but I saw the
clip and I really really loved this clip
because Angela bassett's speech was a
real example of a Class Act okay and she
addressed this topic as we're talking
now about how some people are clamoring
for reparations to the tune of five
million dollars because they're ten
times great grandfather was a slave or
something Angela Bassett instead of
focusing on resentment as so many people
do now at award ceremonies in particular
on the sports fields in public life
Angela Bassett focused on the opposite
gratitude in order for that Destiny to
manifest I think that it requires
courage to have faith it requires
patience
as we just heard and it requires a true
sense of yourself it's not easy because
the path is circuitous and it has many
unexpected detours but by the grace of
God I stand here I stand Here grateful
grateful grateful to the Hollywood
Foreign Press for giving me this honor
along with wakanda forever grateful to
my amazing team who every day each and
every one of them work work along with
me and beside me and on my behalf each
and every day grateful to my family
Courtney B Vance Bronwyn and Slater I
love you from the depths of my heart and
my mother always said that good things
come to those who pray and I see the
truth of that every day
love it what a Class Act I want to put
that part of the speech on repeat I want
to play it in every classroom in America
that's so right not only is it a classy
thing to say add it in a word ceremony
as you're being handed a trophy but it's
just the right attitude to have in life
you can approach life anybody anybody
can approach life from the perspective
of resentment and anxiety and Dread and
fear and general irritation
or any person can approach life from the
perspective of gratitude and the reason
for that is you are not responsible for
the creation of your life you did not
make yourself you did not will yourself
into the world your life is a gift so
every single thing that you get
is a gift from God and you don't deserve
it you didn't earn it that's just a gift
that you were given freely and you owe a
gratitude for that exactly the right way
and she ends it on that note she doesn't
just talk about gratitude out in The
Ether this kind of new age you know it's
the it's the Vibes and the energy man
you know and The Echoes and the ripples
no she's saying it's good to pray
not just send Good Vibes but pray good
things come to those who pray
maybe not Material good things and
plenty of God's favorite people have
suffered enormously
but ultimately good things come to those
who pray
because prayer is conducive to happiness
gratitude is conducive to happiness
that's why the do batters who are
destroying our society are are trying to
get people to stop praying in fact this
just happened over at the Mall of
America that gigantic Mall in
Minneapolis a guy was wearing a t-shirt
said Jesus saves
really simple t-shirt
very basic statement that people have
been wearing on their bodies and their
clothing for 2000 years now you probably
could have found Romans and togas
wearing the phrase Jesus saves and the
authorities probably wouldn't have liked
that either this guy gets harassed
and told to leave by a mall cop for
wearing that offensive statement
[Music]
okay but it's the same thing okay people
have been offended and like I said all
we were asking you is to take your shirt
off you want to make
I didn't say anything
if you want to shop here you need to
take that shirt off it is religious
soliciting there is no soliciting
allowed on off property which is private
property
and they just keep harassing this guy
the clip goes on and on and on the cop
Won't Back Down the guy says I didn't
even say anything
I'm just wearing this shirt and it says
Jesus saves it's not an obscene shirt in
fact if it were an obscene shirt I'm
sure the cops wouldn't have hassled him
but because he's wearing a shirt that
makes a statement that is good and true
and beautiful and conducive to happiness
and human flourishing that's why the
powers that be are after him and this
should come as no surprise
the devil is the prince of this world
okay this is nothing new we like to
Lament The Lizard people over in Davos
because of because they're awful they're
awful and they want to destroy our lives
I'm not downplaying that but this is not
a new thing okay we fight against
principalities and powers and evil and
wickedness in the very high places okay
and all the way down to the very lowest
echelons of that Authority and
enforcement all the way down to this
mall cop trying to shuffle a Christian
out there because what he was wearing on
his shirt the cop considered to be
offensive in a way it is offensive
it's offensive in a very wonderful way
it's offending the the evil
sensibilities of a fallen world but it
is offensive it's making an exclusive
claim it's saying that if you want to be
saved you're saved through God the son
that's how you're saved
what if people say well what but I but I
don't want to worship Jesus okay well
you know that's
I guess that's a you problem I imagine
that's what this man would say he's
wearing a shirt that says Jesus saves
well why can't God save Mankind in some
other way that I would prefer that's
what all sorts of people have been
asking for the last 2000 years why can't
why can't the religion of me be true
whatever my preferred version is how
dare you suggest that your vision is
true I'm going to punish you for doing
that
yeah of course look what they did to
Jesus okay of course they're hustling
this guy out of the Mall of America it
is offensive
but
the shirt is true okay a story I really
wanted to get to on Monday I'm glad we
have like a minute or so to get to it
now
Lisa Marie Presley died Lisa Marie
Presley was the only daughter of Elvis
Presley only child of Elvis Presley she
was only 54 years old some of you may
know I don't know I haven't been totally
open about this on the show
I am a huge Elvis fan I am a die-hard
Elvis fan I've been a huge Elvis fan
since I was five years old I was
pictured in my local newspaper doing a
little Elvis song and dance when I was
in kindergarten I would on occasion do
an Elvis impersonation as part of a
variety show in Hawaii I I just I've got
Elvis memorabilia I've I once visited
The West Wing
for the first time and Graceland for the
first time within a relatively short
period of time I was much more in awe of
Graceland okay I'm just a huge Elvis fan
very very sad that Lisa Marie Presley
died some people are blaming on the
vaccine I don't think there's evidence
of that I mean I wouldn't be surprised I
just I don't see any evidence of that
obviously there were heart problems in
in Elvis's family his mother had heart
problems he had heart problems at least
Marie had heart problems it would seem
uh the Presleys had been pretty open
about their drug problems over the years
uh poor Lisa Marie's son who looked just
like his grandfather died a couple of
years ago so had a hard life the reason
I bring it up at all is one you know
good to pray for the Presleys are really
near and dear to my heart even though
I've never met any of them but also
to make a point that is really important
to to keep in mind especially as we talk
about the rulers of the world the rich
hobnobbing over in Davos with their
private jets and their champagne and all
the rest of it
it's a it's a warning story from Lisa
Marie Presley
Lisa Marie Presley has been Rich every
day of her life
material prosperity
does not determine a happy life
and when I say that everyone's going to
say duh yeah Michael tell me something I
don't know wow what what genius Insight
over here from the philosopher Mr
Michael money doesn't buy happiness I
know I know everybody knows that
except we all forget it we all forget it
all the time
we say ah if I just had a little bit
more money then I'd be happy look at the
people in Davos are those people happy
I don't I don't know they don't seem
like happy people to me Bill Gates
doesn't seem like a happy person to me
the the philosophers of Davos who go on
stage and say God is fake news there is
no soul we are nothing all the little
people we're going to apply them with
drugs and video games they're useless
people they're like we're gonna feed
them crickets and let oh they're sucking
up the air polluting my world oh these
those don't the people who are saying
that
don't seem like very happy people to me
you look at Hollywood you look at the
Rich and Famous
you look at their lives are so
disordered so much of the time and then
you think about the happiest people you
know
poor people have plenty of problems too
but seems to me that
there are very very poor people who are
happy and very very poor people who are
unhappy and the same is true for rich
people which means that the determinant
for happiness is not money the
Communists are wrong the determinant for
happiness is not how much money you have
even the kind of liberal technocrats are
wrong the the determinant for happiness
is not how much money you have the greed
is good hardcore
Wall Street 1980s Republicans let's all
get rich kind of right winger types
their premise is wrong too
it's not to say that money is a bad
thing
money can can be a lovely thing it's not
that the root of money is that money
rather is the root of all evil that's
not true people misquote that quite a
lot the love of money is the root of all
evil
but money itself is the money itself is
just material and your life does not
hinge on material things
because contrary to what all these
Geniuses who think they know so much
better than you think that they can
upend the whole world and run your life
for you all these Geniuses who are
virtually all materialists of One sort
or another
contrary to what they believe you are
more than just your body and you're more
than just your stuff and if you if you
treat yourself like you're just a hunk
of meat to be manipulated by various
chemicals and things that money can buy
you are not going to live a happy life
you're going to be just as happy as
those lizard people over in Switzerland
okay that's our show I'm Michael nol
this is the Michael Knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
[Music]